faux
merci contre et maintenant le derrière
dieudonné le devant c'est comme ça alors
dites-moi à veronica je vous ai vu en
photo dans aulas et vous aviez une robe
absolument j'aimerais qu'on la voit
d'ailleurs cette robe serge khalfon vous
aviez une robe formidable vous vous avez
regarde regarde donc et vous passez
l'aspirateur dans une tenue absolument
délirantes et moi j'ai trouvé hyper sexy
sur cette photo et je vous ai dit enfin
on vous a demandé de venir comme ça
il faisait pas voulu pourquoi parce que
je me suis dit pourquoi pas venir avec
l'aspirateur dans des fermes c'était une
grande dame étape c'était justin rose
pour une photo bâle est vraiment que la
webcam et table quand on voit la flore
j'ai changé je reste de mise et ce avant
quand tu parles n'est pas facile de me
caresser compris préfet ici porte le
bonnet bon donc bon maintenant que j'ai
très bien comme ça aussi un message
social je trouve magnifique tenant
absolument c'est par l aspirateur vous
va très bien comme ça chez moi
alors dites-moi corps quand vous aviez
interviewé clint eastwood la première
question vous lui aviez posé c'était que
pensez vous de moi à oui non c'est fort
c'est parce qu'en fait quand j'étais sur
m6 je voulais pas faire des interviews
classique et quand quand le chargé de
programme a dit il faut que tu interview
de clint eastwood mais qui veut pas
qu'on parle de son fils mais veut pas
qu'on parle de sa femme il veut pas
qu'on parle de sa maison j'ai dit mais
du coup on va parler donc la pire chose
que je lui dis je suis dit moitié fink
pense oui c'est une très belle que moi
si je vous posais la même question alors
que pensez vous de moi
ben je lui dirai c'est très beau c'est
quoi
attendu qu'il a été il a été hyper
étonné il a mis le seconder l'a fait
wayne et j'ai dit et vous m'aimez bien
vous trouvez qu est-ce que ce que je
fais c'est bien mais moi j'étais inconnu
au bataillon était plutôt c'était
humoriste c'est une bonne idée pour un
bon on va vous parler d'interviews qui
n'est pas classique cela va pas être
classique serge est ce qu'on peut
baisser la lumière se tient debout
en voilà
donc valérie et dieudo vous pouvez poser
des questions également un vous aussi
bien évidemment vous connaissez la pige
en 1 alors véronika loubry vous êtes
animatrice chanteuse comédienne
mannequin vous présenter si vous
présentez sur nc m
une émission qui passe le samedi et le
dimanche à 18h qui s'appelle les clips
sont à vous c'est ça très bien
alors vous êtes né je vous présente donc
ses produits de répondre pour le moment
vous êtes né à saint brévin les pins
votre maman travail et la sécurité
sociale et voilà comment les habitants
de saint brevin brévinois les brévinois
et votre maman donc rallié la sécu et
votre papa à l'aérospatiale à l'âge de 8
ans et frère ça sert à quoi vous ai déjà
les concerts payants à l'âge de 8 ans
vient je faisais des petits spectacles
pour pour les petites du quartier je
faisais payer effectivement mais sa
maman maman ne savait pas les autres
mamans non plus mais c'est une petite
anecdote assez assez marrante deschamps
pourrait vous chantiez je ressentais pas
à l'époque c'était un nick hornby boney
m des trucs un peu qui vont avec et avec
l'époque j'étais contente de chanter le
quatuor du peuple attention mariani
cornichons et plus je connaissais le
répertoire parker il arrivait frère
jacques
tout ça c'est son bureau je pense que
c'est vraiment pas commun d'être à la
mode ouais certes on est bonne du curé
joie et c'est facile d'avoir du style
quand on a une fille comme moi j comme
le prêtre lecture et les piqûres des
grenouilles à tout ça le bateau on donne
des idées avec annie cordy
bon et alors à la fin vous vous
distribuez des journal de mickey comme
deuxième sens de la promotion déjà en
fait mon temps à fabriquer un petit
théâtre et alors je sais le journal mais
le jeu
le mic est en fait je le lisais je leur
demandais de m'applaudir beau c'est
assez bizarre
après je chantais leur donne un goûter à
la fin je les ai payés parce qu'il
fallait bien que j'achète le journal de
mickey trash quand même car c'est
maintenant vous gagnez plus d'argent
vous étiez quelqu'un qu'on était bien
vous appelez la commande c'est ça mais
là comme en deux alors en 4e ou
infirmiers dans l'est dans les toilettes
ouais ouais j'ai regardé par la fed
écrire sur la guerre des scénarii vous
étiez la fille de jean paul belmondo du
salon mais j'ai dû dire ça une fois oui
c'est vrai c'est juste et chez les cours
il faisait quoi elle s'enfermer dans les
toilettes pour les scénarii où elle
était la fille de jean paul on lit un
crs on n'a pas le droit d'être on est
dans la cour de récré à prendre entre
dans la classe près de moi je
m'enfermais pour pas que les les pions
me voit et j'écrivais je passais mon
temps à écrire des scénarii où je
m'imaginais puisse pas pourquoi à
l'époque aussi fille de jean paul besset
pour jean paul besset pas pourquoi à
l'époque l'a longtemps
il ya ce risque d'un tendon il ya plus
de 20 pouces à l'âge de 3 ans vous êtes
aperçu que
vous étiez fait pour faire rire serre
que je me demandais ce que je faisais
sur terre alors quand je commence quand
j'ai fait rire est un peu des gens j'ai
bon j'existe 36 15 donc là vous monter à
paris après avoir été réceptionniste
vendeuse serveuse a eu à paris pour
faire même qu'un pas tous en même temps
non pas tout ça en même temps comme
comme vous d'ailleurs on est tous montés
à paris un jour et alors là ce qui s'est
passé si vous allez à saint tropez pour
faire un casting est à 300 candidate et
vous êtes choisis par tf1 c'est quand
même le coup de bol énorme
dominique ancien rechercher une fille
avait 300 filles à peu près pour ce
casting pour partir aux bahamas et elle
m'appelle trois quatre jours à prendre
dix ans le casting a duré trois mois et
la dernière sélection m'a dit tu pars
dans trois jours bahamas tournée ouais
c'était super
vous êtes allé tourner le trésor de pago
pago voilà alors après vous avez fait là
combien d'émissions ne sait jamais ça
voilà pourquoi je suis plein d'histoires
en comprenait pas bien le jeu et vous
traducteur moi c'est les news non non
non parce qu'on comprenait pas bien les
passer sous l'eau on compensait le
dépasser ouais c'était entièrement nom
n'a pas fait le paquebot pago les
trésors le trésor de pago pago alors à
peu devenue une carrière absolument nous
renoncions vous avez vous avez une
carrière à son si ça vous passez du
trésor de pago pago aux écrans du savoir
sur la cinquième ce qui est quand même
pas rien après les sur m6 pour faire
star news après sur tf1 pour faire là la
mini fureur vous faites paradis d'enfer
alors voilà on peut pas dire vous ne
pourrez pas méchant si je dis que là
dedans y'a pas un truc qui a explosé le
compteur fait ses vrais bons non ça
s'arrête pas là mais on perd des
opérations
pas s'il ya des fans qui s'en
souviennent de star news de sporever wii
sports événements si c'était pas mal
c'est vrai que ça pas marqué non plus
dans les annales croisé le jura la mine
histoire la mini fût relais adore
chanter pour les ados voilà et alors
après donc fait un disque avec nous ou
maraka comme écrivait chanson de jeanne
mas et de ses fans il est de monaco chef
de molac c'est lui qui a écrit ouragans
et vous fait une chanson qui s'appelle c
dans l'air vous entendez cinquante mille
exemplaires alors 70 milles quand on
vous dit mais qu'attend non mais quand
on lui dit que c'est pas terrible en
paix vous dites que vous avez une
réponse quand on vous dit que c'est pas
terrible dit c'est quand même la
contenance du parc des princes
oui c'était c'était marrant de dire que
c'était moi ce stade de france non c'est
vrai que c'est pas terrible mais bon ça
n'a pas été bien suivie à chaque fois
moi j'ai pas eu de pot j'ai eu des
problèmes avec la prod ou avec la maison
de disque est toujours eu un problème
donc c'est pas très grave
ceci étant c'est le fait d'assumer ce
qu'on a fait moi j'assume j'ai passé des
bons moments à chaque fois que j'ai fait
quelque chose j'en ai tiré des bonnes ou
des mauvaises expériences je leur ferais
je leur ferai pas le tout moi j'ai aimé
ce que j'ai fait à un moment donné dans
ma vie voilà le problème c'est vous dire
si vous avez jamais été vais-je à mes
marques et une case à la télé j'avais 7
ou le faire que si vous aviez tout même
endroit pendant longtemps mais c'est
tellement bougie vous avez beaucoup
bougé voilà vous avez zappé aussi vite
que les téléspectateurs
c'était une bonne façon on remarque
l'absence d'issue retomber sur vous l
avoir vu véronique à la télévision non
voyez par exemple voilà parce que c'est
peut-être pas une bonne ben oui vous
aimez pas on va en parler après vous
voit capote rapport à la télé est ambigu
un rapport ambigu à la télé oui je me
souviens que vous êtes venu chez moi
chanter la chanson assez censé en tirer
andy rihs lâché 10 candidats chez
drouant chantent en direct la dernière
émission de france
chantant dimanche en direct et s'appelle
dans tous les sens et c'est pas tout
mais c'est pas tous les jours une chance
pour moi tu qu'on joue mais non c'était
bien les brouilles et c'est dans l'air
s'était passé dans l'air c'est pas si
mal de 50 mille exemples non mais je
compte nommer
dans l'air et danser dans l'art et dans
c dans l'air c'est dans laquelle il
s'est alors donc en revanche sur le plan
privé
j'ai vu tellement de problèmes donc
parce que d'abord vous êtes sortis comme
on dit avec alexandre debanne qui est
plutôt un beau garçon si j'avais pensé
mais si bien sûr
bah oui alexandre après trois ans après
l'accident
juste avant l'accident et alors à près
de vous non non ce à cause de la moto
est alors après vous êtes non mais j'ai
raté deux trois fois 6 nations basse en
forme il faut que tu bosses mais j'ai
raté de trois filles je suis pas allé
chez le dentiste pour gala il acheter on
peut pas dire les gens dits j'achète
voici je ne sais pas moi si je le vois
celle de voilà c'est ça voilà je crois
pas sinon je reçois gratos à la radio je
serai et c'est la première chose sur
lequel on se jette tous vient d'ailleurs
lundi vous y êtes là c'est vrai ouais
merde avec vous alors
et après donc vous rencontré votre mari
qui s'appelle robert therry taous et sa
vérité alors jamais bien compris il est
champion du windsurf ou de funboard
windsurf et cinq d'entre eux mêmes
choses c'est pas une question qui est
décent qui dissertent mais s'est mise
d'accord
et alors quand vous l'avez rencontrée
c'est tellement le coup de foot je vais
vraiment eu un vrai coup de foudre
vous êtes resté dix minutes avant de
pouvoir poser la première question
non c'est pas vrai c'est vous qui l'avez
les ai pas inventés bien été écrit mais
en tout cas c'est vrai qu'on parle pas
la même langue
les charges en mai
ce qui est écrit et ce qui est vrai vous
le savez pertinents c'est loin alors non
c'est pas vrai bon c'est pas vrai c'est
vrai que c'est lors d'une interview mais
j'avais pu lui parler tout de suite et
bien sûr en revanche d'aller dîner
ensemble le premier soir oui ça vous en
bouche un coin ça bah moi j'ai du mal
avec des affaires civiles alors le
terreau idéal à dijon le premier soir
alors vous a dîné d'inata within et a
alors bon vous n êtes tous été très très
très clair l'un vis-à-vis de l'autre un
avec écran d'ordi on a déjà nous nous
avions déjà livre prenez vous manque
nous avions déjà bien vécu chacun de
notre côté et on se l'est pas cacher mes
distances en huile retranchements on
aspire à voir
on a fait des ménages ouais c'était
l'amour fou parce qu'une fois il parle
qu'il est revenue de du pacifique pour
un week-end à deauville c'est vrai salon
marais habite hawaï
moi je sais et c'est vrai qu'il faut
plus de 22 heures d'avion pour venir il
est venu pour un week-end mais le fait
souvent effectivement
ouais bon beh mengue deux heures pour
retourner chez vous chez lui déjà leader
de l'autre a le temps de partir alors
vous pas fait comme ça qu'on s'est fait
laminer fureur vous dites que je pars
hawaïen
si ça marche je reviens sinon cécile ami
mr marche pas je reviens plus et ça va
pas marcher vous êtes prévenus pourquoi
j'avais pas dû se dire ça quand même
c'était diffusé qu'en - j'étais hawaï et
c'est vrai qu'on m'appelait tous les
matins pour donner les l'audience est
sûre je voulais voulait pas revenir tout
de suite parce que quand je reste un
vrai jeu reste de trois mois et en fait
j'ai été rappelé pour faire autre chose
pour passer des castings pour la suisse
que c'est pas parce que vous trouvez pas
vos bouillon cube à voile parce que le
face à n'importe quoi c'est pas vrai
n'ont jamais dit ça j'ai dit arrêtez de
dire jamais j'ai dit que j'avais dit le
seul problème
voici jean pierre coffe j'ai dit que je
n'arrivais pas à trouver tous les
ingrédients pour faire de la cuisine
parce que moi je cuisine non mais c'est
pas attendez c'est pas parler des
bouillons de tubes j'avais dit qu'en
général je trouvais rien quoi
oui mais non mais c'est quoi c'est pas
ces faits constatent donc robert y
laisse effectivement à 18h devant des
référendaires vous dire notre bob 09 le
ca ressort à 0 et à 18 heures de vol
dont kiel à construire si j'allais voulu
y vient mais vous y allez vous ouais une
semaine tous les tous les deux moi c'est
ça non non je suis allé deux mois la
novembre avant qu'il a construit une
maison pour vous là bas mois d'avril
ils avaient construit avant que j'arrive
à dire on est au mois d'avril
oui pourquoi emilie venir
tout le monde se demande alors à temps
elle il ya une semaine tous les deux
tout le monde se demande tout le monde
se demande c'est pas tout le monde d'en
bas c'est tout le monde se demande mais
vous allez dire j'espère faisait pas
confiance non parce que c'est une phrase
qui est assez joli je trouve
vous avez dit avec robert on se voit pas
tout le temps et vous avez dit c'est
comme les bonbons quand on vous en
priver le jour où vous les sucer quel
bonheur
d'ailleurs la porte cette adresse
alors vous êtes amélie c'est écrit c'est
comme un bonbon quand on quand on en a
plus on en a envie et quand on les a
battus voilà j'ai dit ça j'ai pas dis
suisse et du tout j'ai mal j'ai mal
notées dans cette phrase mais bon je
vais faire un bébé pour l'an 2000
non ah ouais donc je vous ai dit moi
j'ai bien fermé bien que ça prenne trois
mois valérie elle en veut pas valérie
papaud lance pas pour l'instant ça je me
dis série et bertrand 110 pas pour la à
bertrand c'est fini et encore à nairobi
c'est la grosse boulette la 900 il ya la
moindre des choses c'est de se
renseigner si c'est parce que vous
faites par ce qui est peut-être un homme
devant sa télévision là qui est
complètement inespéré
et qu'est ce que vous lui faire cet
homme thierry ardisson et et à valérie
valérie a su surmonter grâce à grâce à
ce film
elle s'est plongée variable succès mais
mais là vous avez fait pas chez fendre l
a assez fait la boulette mais je sais
que vous est effondrée je ne sais
sincèrement effondré mais bon je sais
vous aurez assez facilement et
rapidement mais mes pensées aux autres
voilà à la télévision faut aussi penser
à moi j'ai toujours été bon alors vous
projet on va terminer sur vos projets
veronica si vous voulez bien vous vous
dites chaque fois que j'en parle mais
projet ça n'aboutit pas et j'ai l'air
ridicule
je vous préviens vous avez dit je rêve
de faire fort boyard mais qu'on compte
pas sur moi pour faire d'inde à côté
d'un animateur c'est pareil c'est celle
ci d'un je sais pas vous mais pas pour
les raisons mêmes sera dit dom c'est pas
un mot à moi c'est marrant ce que moi je
suis pour tous à ce qu'on dise qu'on ait
dit ou pas 10 mai
les journalistes ont tendance à donner
députés les propos acerbes
je sais pas pourquoi je dis pas d'un
vocabulaire elle voulait faire le père
fouras c'est finalement elle n'avait pas
la clé mais les gros cela vous êtes trop
grand show quittent le territoire est
mannequin est trop grande pour faire
battre par tous je sais que c'est sur
cette chaîne mais quand même
ouais innervant fort boyard 45 minutes
pour retrouver cette clé ça nous énerve
déjà au bout de cinq minutes quand on a
perdu des mélodies ouais j'ai pas
regardé ce qu'elle n'en voulait plus
faire potiche c'est vrai quoi c'est oui
enfin c'est à dire que la sur mcm chez
une émission qui me plaît
interview des gens qui me plaît ça et ça
change un petit peu c'est vrai que ça
change un petit peu effectivement cette
façon quoi qu'il arrive dans les
émissions que j'ai fait quand t'es à
côté d'un animateur
tu es un peu relégués au rang d' entre
parenthèses g phase iib d'un gîte être
dit potiche parce que l'animateur vous
pas qu'on dise plus que fera pas plus
que lui mais il veut qu'on ne pas être
non un faire-valoir de l'animateur c'est
vrai que c'est assez dur maintenant sur
un thème je suis tout seul
le muguet oui on va bel et bien sûr
faire une enquête très finement
valérie a touché trois marques et de ses
fils j'étais me faire valoir
bon alors vous avez quand même votre
entreprise de savon au monoï donc
toujours non oui avec de la fleur de
tiaré à une entreprise ne connais pas du
tout effrayé une beauté c'est moi qui
l'initient à savoir si on voit dans le
film à quel point à quel point vous avez
été convertie par valérie lemercier aux
produits de beauté on va voir ça tout à
l'heure bon écoute et on a fini dernière
question comment va votre ami qu'elle
joue super jeu vous serre ges qu'on peut
voir tout ça est très amis là on va vous
voir toutes les deux avec catch ou la
voilà sont très amies toutes les deux
donc et même max avec
voilà ouais c'est ce calendrier c'est
bien ce calendrier marié tombeau la
prochaine pourrait comme maire ça fait
qu'à chausser devancer veronica ce
c'était la différence à gosnay de
remercier ses galères il fait pipi
debout devant le film bon merci bonjour
je la trouve plus sympathique que cache
ou huawei a beaucoup plus sympathique et
j'avais s'est vexé pour quelques
questions vous prenez et ça je trouve ça
vachement malgré tout avec le sourire
ouais on lui dit que c'est une des
leçons ça vachement sympa mais cache ou
comment ça va au fait avec ses fiches
recettes fils qu'elle joue comment ça va
avec son jules
enfin vous allez arrêter cendrillon mais
on en a parlé ici moi je joue et c'est
pas elle qui va qui va qualifier celui
de notre dame de paris la bombe a très
bien travaillé
oui on va merci à bientôt donc tous les
dimanches et tous les samedis à 18h